today in our show Piderman webs up big
bucks this weekend whoo there's a Wonder
Woman sequel news
and so much more on today's fat Nana
Batman or wider men on spider-man oh
thank you Internet man and it gives that
one
[Music]
Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm mark
barnard okay spider-man did alright this
weekend this movie made all the money
now it made a little bit of cash it made
its I believe the second biggest
spider-man movie of all time what would
be the first you say to yourself oh god
be that first by remember we're probably
amazing spider-man 2 which is less of
the very me series
you'd be wrong is it the angel Garfield
picture you'd be wrong there I would be
that leaves one choice left
dancing jazzy spider-man was the biggest
of all times emo emo man banana nana
nana day when you're a web you're a web
to it um that's my it's not bad
auditioning for the Rainbows bone is the
raindrops on I wasn't up to following
goes to its popular weight with that in
three where to that's in three yeah
that's be like when spider-man gives up
his [ __ ] and decides it's gonna be
regular human dude he's super [ __ ]
happy
that was three I love those two that was
three
where is it to tell us it or not yeah
tell us how well I'm wrong I think it's
too good I do I don't think there's any
moment in three because if that makes
you go yeah oh it was three was like
three felt like a dare agree with
legible in these movies a double dog day
let's see if we can make it in such a
way that people who like the first two
are mad and it's about the third is this
good kids got some cool moves as you can
hear it's a circus of canine excellent
you're measuring is a foot now because
they know that we're talking about
spider-man hey we're talking about
[ __ ] spider-man bowie shaggy right
here's the big Chucky here's the big
news spider-man made some money how much
was it
let me check my insta phone two hundred
fifty seven million dollars world oh
sure what's the domestic I live in
America talk in mark so I only murder
American numbers America first mob god
oh my god
140 million dollars eristic [ __ ] that
now it's over five days yes that's like
because we had a holiday weekend still
[ __ ] huge sure money for the sixth
spider-man movie yes for the second
fourth fifth reboot of spider-man six
spider-man movie third iteration in the
second time we've seen them in within
two years because he's a civil war so
based on all that movie math this movie
should have made a couple bucks and
that's it should have done what they're
calling valerian money that's coming
soon which is to say good but not
[ __ ] 140 ml being more than two
francs together but still exactly so
this makin as much as it did proves what
we've known all along Kevin Feige should
be given every superhero thing ever
he just wants the Marvel Universe but if
I'm [ __ ] Warner Brothers I'd be like
please do both like Wilco finances would
combine these universes let us play with
you smooth even though you guys know how
to do it
Sony should be doing cartwheels and they
are Tom Rothman now in charge over there
and whatnot Amy Pascal who is like
weathering the storm when you know broke
the email hack happened and and and Kim
jong-un was like I'm gonna take on
America because I love the under alien
movies what a wacky time that was did
you imagine if there's a world in which
let's say 15 years ago 20 years from now
yes Warner Brothers and Marvel and
Disney sit down and be like you know
what contest to the champions can we
cross these two universes together yeah
can we should we we asked Marvel vs. DC
yes Marvel the historic series that
everyone was a fight an imperfect to the
amalgam universe for a moment thank
goodness for a moment for a moment um
yeah I can see it come on dude here not
in our lifetime or maybe here like you
know we've watched technology jump into
sexually to
over the course of the last 30 years
alone that one has to has to anyone with
a brain or logic has to cop to the fact
and we ended landed and we stole all
their shoes or we've just gotten so much
better at this technology [ __ ] so what
happens now I just said to mark for to
show began I said man I was getting
ready to be like what is the next
superhero movie and we literally just
had one one of the biggest we're talking
about it right now a week ago but we
have no sense of satiety for these films
and the the audience I feel is only
getting larger some people have they
write so many bubble articles like
here's the superhero movie on a bubble
bubble about to burst
obviously not six [ __ ] spider-man
movie third iteration of the characters
second time he could see him in two
years and people are still a tickle
month for good money because they're
doing it right what does that do the
comic book movies if you do comic book
movie right if you can show to [ __ ] up
it's like Field of Dreams though with
webs in it if you build it it'll shoot
webs over it and into your [ __ ] face
with bills mmm that rods of cat throwing
money at Sony and because because Disney
doesn't own a piece of this I reread
this weekend am yeah there's just the
creative Kevin Feige was just like skin
in the game here's my skin son talent I
need money I bring the town and he put
that talent to work and rewrote and or
denied or helped develop and stuff yeah
so Sony's got all the money in the game
but you know what they trade off is like
Spider Man is in right vengers so that's
that's the lucrative part of all this
sweet is plump right the plush just
having spider-man be able to play with
with like all the other characters the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but in any
event everybody deserves a big pat on
the back man it's most of all of course
the director even John Watts and the
many screenwriters were like 96 yeah but
15 of them commercial for a good movie
hey you know I'm saying if it takes
[ __ ] 15 writers to make something
that enjoyable
take it take all my money hire 30
writers calling everybody gets paid
there's one voice it smells like over
there
and the modern-day Stanley of the
moderate of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is is definitely Kevin buggy
like like this guy if they put posters
up of like movie producers I like I
would be honestly I'd be tempted to not
only hit that poster like I remember
when Quentin did when Pope fiction
happened and it was [ __ ] huge you
could buy in spencer's a poster of
Quentin Tarantino and it's it was said
and he was like he was wearing open
shirt if I remember correctly and all
this and it said It's Showtime
and I'm literally just like Oh [ __ ] we
salute his entire catalog of work which
was to that point but like people love
them so much he wore into the zone
poster now that we know there's
precedent if they put out and I'm not
doing this to get a job I don't want to
make tomorrow movie I just want to watch
him although it would be in one I'm just
saying
oh yeah but if they made a Kevin Feige
pretty please if they made a Kevin Feige
poster I would be tempted to not only
buy it but get it framed what if they
did it like an IMAX giveaway like if you
go to the IMAX and hey Kevin Feige
staring over you from your bedroom
hey Kevin's wedding a big poster yeah my
bus stop in yeah looks like I'm not
hanging on the ceiling just honking up
at me not tacky some classy like this
It's Showtime both to that side that's
like it nothing says classy it's not the
director with a naval shirts on you look
it up I bet you get somebody on eBay in
fact when we're done with go buy one
because I wished I had bought one in the
90s and like this worth happening i he
lives up the hill we go over me like
sign this jeez speaking of Quentin
what's on the back in the spider-man but
while we're talking about Quentin [ __ ]
it somebody just dropped [ __ ] news
today man like there's been something in
the air some people in Los Angeles have
been like Oh Quentin this Quentin
Mattingly could getting ready to clean
rumblin Queens out about went and back
he was away and now he's home he's
getting ready dot dot dot and it broke
on who broke the news but
you know this being the age of the
Internet you want to credit anybody but
somebody broke the million newsman let
it be broke Quentin Tarantino working on
a brand new movie about wait for it no
not the Old West know about old Los
Angeles about the Manson murders
indeed dying of Sharon Keaton Benedict
Canyon that's brilliant I know who does
that
what do you got five six hundred nurses
he's going crazy with glee and
Harrisburg there that's thinking because
that's thinkin that is second though
everyone loves that story for some
reasons creepy [ __ ] horrible the
death of Sharon Tate at the [ __ ] night
and her unborn child
yes she's nine months pregnant at the
knives of the [ __ ] Manson cult
because it has people those things it
has everyone has Fame and has murder it
at Hollywood I know but like and I'm all
for it I'm glad this is perfect marriage
before we go anywhere is perfect
marriage of material and artists like
it's one of those things where we just
talked about before the show and you
step back from your like I've [ __ ] in
any tackle this sooner this is why I
made for Quentin but why is this story
like there have been so many other
brutal murders like if you're in the
murders and [ __ ] which I personally not
but why is this story like so compelling
that people like keep tabs on it they do
remember like the David Duchovny show
Aquarius was about that like every true
crime show does their and then
periodically at the interview [ __ ]
Manson himself what is part of it I
think part of it is every man alive you
know that like this Specter of that
horror has never actually faded away and
that it was all about like as we also
talked about performers that are rolling
that Manson's alleged master plan was to
foment a race war in Los Angeles by
killing a blonde lady and blaming it on
black guys I guess one was very well
thought well I mean mastermind maybe of
what alt murder kids if you're any plan
involves the taking of another life even
if it's baby Hitler in a time machine
you're probably doing it wrong take no
lives unless the band Walsh it how do
you hand
work you know for shooting that you
whatever let's not get into that yeah
morality is not our strong suit this
ain't hacksaw Ridge anion Andrew
Garfield this is damn sure a hell kids
it so we're not arguing that no although
he does feel the same way
get mark drunk forget it hey sugar tits
existed to me am i gay I wouldn't call
him sugary I said none of this I call
him stevia Stevie Stevie Stevie anyway
any event Quentin Tarantino is working
on a new movie this is reason to rejoice
the fact that it's a movie about the
Manson Family yes
you got my money got my money anyway but
you definitely got my money
rumor is he's gone out to an old
associate Brad Pitt who we worked with
inglourious basterds take my money
imagine if you please Manson shut up
imagine rhabdo not to shut up imagine it
Brett I came to say
it's actor thinking but now who who's
got the list
he's got five six hundred nurses I hear
he's going watch yeah did I hear is
going cold I hear a lot of things I he's
doing well here's the very well
Glengarry Glen Ross not the big hallway
scene that everybody knows always be
closed this is the lesser and Harrison
our kid in the cars be who choose yes ah
cue people you've got back very Brad
Pitt playing [ __ ] Charles Manson and
the rumor the rumor is that he's also
Quentin met with Margot Robbie to play
Sharon Tate I mean get gummy internet
Doolittle search and you'll see that she
looks very here something like that look
good and I like my wife don't give me
such a good landmark I like my house I
like everything about Kevin Smith it's a
way it like that I'm like doing it wrong
so now I'm doing it wrong all of that
just sounds like like smart people
creative people
mega billions Giants getting together to
build worlds and universes and I'm like
wonder we get for Jay and Silent Bob
I wonder who won't say no Wow
Margo really that's a great call yeah
baby I Sharon Tate Sharon Tate take my
money I heard I read somewhere I heard I
read that uh Jennifer long babe I read
that they heard oh where they are that
Jennifer Lawrence you might have went
out there was something but they were
look at all this room or not home to me
every day Sharon Tate that means who
squeaky Fromme who could be who knows
man but whatever it is I'm on board
throw that Barkham quentin tarantino is
in arguably one of the five greatest
living American filmmakers and I would I
mean I don't want salt anybody but like
aren't I allowed to have an opinion
totally my favorite their [ __ ] jump
on this come at me bro
I will also argue I'll hold my beer
Marvin I got this I I do I love him to
death I swear to God and you know I say
that as a guy who is I'm it's not like
I'm on board with every single thing
some things I like more than others but
he's balls on film and I don't think
that necessarily is what you need to be
or something like I don't know [ __ ] him
he's just so good at it
I'm the American master I will also say
I am firmly of the belief that he is the
most powerful film maker in Hollywood
because yes Steven Spielberg hold on
they give up [ __ ] saying I'll take a
single for this ha ha ha
give me that [ __ ] single now like
they're they're filmmakers and get
things like Michael Bay can if you want
to make a Transformers movie Michael Bay
will do that if you want to make a
Spielberg movie that feels and looks
like a Spielberg movie he's got money
for that nobody in the world wanted to
give Quentin Tarantino 60 million
dollars to make Django Unchained nobody
wants to make nobody wakes up in the
morning who wants to do says you know I
want to make a slave revolt vengeance
picture where where like I wanted Will
Smith couldn't get Will Smith so I'll
get buggin yes Jamie Foxx can whip white
dudes for like an hour and a half and
somehow not only get people to spend
that money but get a hundred million
dollars where the people that come
to get more than that I mean it made
more than 12 years a slave the good
slave movie directed by a black dude did
not make as much as The Revenge Fantasia
directed by a white dude who thinks he's
a black dude strong words correspondent
mark regardin we'll be sending it back
into the field short well you know what
to be fair I just sucked his dick for
like three minutes I am you and what you
said was positive too I'm not saying
anything better than I like I don't like
I don't dislike any Quentin Tarantino
movie your art your thesis though is
that who else can [ __ ] do that who
well Damon I don't make very good you
right like so is Spielberg cannot walk
into any studio to you know I don't to
make a slave movie about the slave cuz
you made a slave movie about that lawyer
who defends the slave that's why I'm
stuff does ain't no understood the line
I stole from zeg Mary um okay yeah we
love Quentin here so [ __ ] there it is
better way get ready for that [ __ ] but
anyway back to spider-man it made all
the money's all the money and it
Congrats to all involved and stuff like
that I'm sure they're getting ready for
[ __ ] - as we speak
they gotta be if they're not well I mean
the keys ah there's a website called
movie pilot picked up our TV that's the
weirdest about like on the last episode
we were theorized and actually I wonder
if Peter Parker could become the new
Tony Stark if Tony Stark dies and
Avengers the next Avengers movie and it
was a whimsy and and somebody at movie
pilot wrote it as an article and they
were like let's break it down like not
saying that's going to happen but they
were like he's very clear that he's just
spitballing but they're like you know it
could and they found thank you for
validating my fantasies one movie pilot
to validate all my fantasies
well like some involved Jay Mewes get it
done speaking of things we said that
made it into the internet new category a
new category we had we had waxed
philosophical what the Wonder Woman
sequel could be or where it could take
place or who could be in it and we were
kind of fond of the idea that that what
if it was in the Cold War what if it was
you know it was us versus Russia what if
it was you know three glass toast what
it was all about the Berlin Wall
dropping what it was all about that
stuff and and paranoia and shifting
alliances and Steve Trevor can maybe
come back as Martian Manhunter we talked
about such things news broke today
please shut the [ __ ] up you don't even
realize what a brilliant segue that was
daddy's nowhere was going I would have
got to wonder whether that was desk get
office [ __ ] dick dogs hop on the
Segway with me
let's see according to Screen Rant which
first reported this Open Screen Rant you
know it's true
Olson Kevin Smith and the rap has
confirmed the rap there for real if it's
in the rap it ain't crap makes Kevin
spool that Wonder Woman to would be a
period piece with Princess Diana facing
off against the Soviet Union during the
1980s babies yeah which is a little bit
later than I thought
but it's still the end of the Cold War
interesting yes and they've also
mentioned that Steve Trevor's coming
back with Chris bonds coming back Chris
Pine they do have a Warner Brothers has
an option on Chris Pine to bring it back
for sequel and again white wouldn't
choose I look I like him as the Martian
Manhunter and if they don't do it I'm
not going to say I'm going to be
disappointed but it's gonna be a bit
disappointing if they don't do it
because that's [ __ ] it's a solid idea
but they could also just do it if she's
fighting Russians which might be bucket
darling uh they could just do it like
she gets gassed or drugged and then so
she sees Steve they're like you know
he's got to come back into this play but
not like I survived they're not going to
play that car no I don't think you can
yeah that's I don't want to hear that
[ __ ] never [ __ ] cheapen what he did
the sacrifice he made in Wonder Woman
God gentle-like that's what you remember
about Wonder Woman I'm like yes the man
gave his life for the lady
for the ladies I was just one death I
remember the one that was happening in
the movie my wife was a hardcore
feminist soon as like she he's taken off
and just gotcha beep aah aah
and I wasn't calmed down he doesn't save
the day she's the hero does
he has to have an arc his art just goes
off into the sky yeah the kids like you
know not only should Wonder Woman defeat
Ares she should get in the plane fly the
plan to explodes and then fly back to
their invisible plane I was like you
gotta share some of the story for the
characters yeah he can save the day
she's gonna save the world
totally totally just fine so he better
not come back as him the other thing
they could do would be kind of shitty
would you find out that Steve Trevor had
a wife back home who was pregnant with a
young Steve Trevor oh but then that
young Steve Trevor was born 1940 by the
time he gets to 1980 and this picture
change later
she's he's the son of Steve Trevor off
Steve Trevor jr. keep [ __ ] him Trevor
boys Wonder Woman I didn't say that No
maybe she'd had some sanctity being like
wow I knew your father at home real well
real world one night but that's a way
you could do it I still prefer the
Martian Manhunter method above all the
hardcore DC fan that would be amazing
I mean look I'm they got my money anyway
but you would have I'd steal his money
and give you his money if you did what
he said to do I would get because that
third job he'd get while he'd also get
money because we do like he said it
thirst for money but then they'd be like
if we own the comics and he said it face
buddy and then they'd be like nobody
give a tissue scribe out his money that
he had long Joe there would be money and
that's why you never share your creative
ideas of anybody I mean all right man I
hope that's [ __ ] all true I hope so
too because if you said with deadly
seriousness I also - that sounds good
though I really like honestly like I'm
such a [ __ ] I was like oh I'm sure
they'll go to World War two and I'm like
[ __ ] it dude it's been done in English
in like if she can't kill Hitler what's
point of sending her there and Quentin
already did it uphill so [ __ ] yeah blah
they're gonna send her of the 80s and
fight the cold war and [ __ ] Reagan and
shoulder pads like war yeah Dennis
Miller I mean that's the problem with
the 80s is that that fashion was [ __ ]
like due to 60s where everybody looks
great
and what's been like maybe what they're
doing maybe it's conscious conscious
maybe they're conscious maybe they're
like look we consciously went to world
war one because what [ __ ] nobody's done
World War one that much and we got to do
something cool with in World War one so
they are leaning toward the Cold War era
what would be the cool thing that we're
missing that they're like oh [ __ ]
maybe she stops the Cuban Missile Crisis
and that's the 60s and the x-men did
that already
oh god Danny you're right well I mean I
mean you also write about being big did
they say was definitely the 80 they said
during the eighties which again this is
all tangential and rumor and circumspect
and all of that should I predict an
opening montage sequence set to my
Shubham I look forward to it Valley Jack
is wrong we didn't write out the fire
yeah doo-doo-doo-doo condor Wallman blah
blah
look at valley Jenkins can't do it you
have to willing men here who can not
only direct the picture but do the
themes long as you just turn with our
mouths you know you're not fit that fat
Billy Joel money now [ __ ] that our
versions one cheaper yeah Geoff Johns
and patty Jenkins are apparently
developing script patty Jenkins Dylan
talks to return she has yet to sign on
the dotted line you'll come back they
will pay her that woman I saw footage of
her Megan I movie they keep releasing
more and more footage because she's
become something of a name and is every
not just for a wonderful movie but also
because the movie bilk records in truth
so now he's trying to see more footage
of her like they put on the Instagram
and stuff and the movie continues to
make Luke wood and whatnot but those two
look like they're having a good time I
mean you know it's like when he got
those bond of scenes packages they never
show people being like why did I do this
obviously horrible decision he has their
their marketing but still like she
looked like she was legit having a good
time you know Rhonda camera with gal
gadot and Wonder Woman is officially out
gross Suicide Squad holy [ __ ]
speaking of which yeah I'm back on the
set you don't even get the [ __ ] I'm
mad at that in the sec laser take us
home Suicide Squad to which is set to
start filming in
2018 without director David Ayer David
Ayer is not coming back David Ayer is
not coming I heard David hares directing
something though something big on
Netflix
yeah yeah he directed that yeah with a
madman Lando's grip
Will Smith starring huge movie yeah for
Netflix like this big fantasy Netflix is
biggest yeah effort single button movie
or series it's moving it's a it's
something they're they're being very
cagey about what it is but it's like
what if we live in a world of works and
wizards and magic and [ __ ] but there are
also cops and so what if will smith was
an orc cop so yeah so it's less well
whatever I'm sure I'm sure they know if
they're doing well but it sounds a
little like like was that movie like
dead no ripped oh yeah I PD RIPD ystem
piece Department know whatever not maybe
you know I'm not reducing it you know
what sure it's gonna be amazing
that kids talented I think max is a very
talented kid he's writes like my bucker
just dude goes asleep and while he's
sleeping his brains right in the script
you got another one
he's prolific to Middle East but let's
use iMovie future David David I are
there air went over to direct that so
and he will provide for me Argentina he
don't quite well you will probably
producer on this because everybody
sticks around as a producer in some
fashion maybe he chose to not to ii
totally and he could I think he's still
involved in someone would Gotham City
sirens which I don't know it's right
there but uh the person who is hopefully
Warner Brothers wants to take over
there's a guy whose name I'm about to
butcher Zhang Cole a Sarah it's
pronounced Kevin Smith mark who directed
the shark thriller the shallows that
wasn't me has emerged all one [ __ ]
movie with Blake Lively yeah that's
Warner Brothers movie to anything like
lightly in a shark they all keep it in
the family um yeah that movies I've kind
of dope that flick the trapper was yeah
I mean he's the front-runner now to home
Suicide Squad the eggs showing Warner's
initially circled this is trade speak
like circling czar thing to do in the
sudden lamb back in the conversation
because it's Hollywood speak and I am in
Hollywood
what is initially circle now gets in the
helm the project but script delays push
a production star Gibson moved on so
Hickson
love the flick salsa service TV I
recently received a new treatment
written by Zack pen from Avengers ready
player one the matrix reboot / sequel /
prequel then risk it will now be ready
wait Zack pen is doing the matrix reboot
sequel mm-hmm uh and you were the first
draft of Avengers and just came off of
ready player wanted the hope to you know
the whole movie that I like ah ed
annoyed yeah yeah yeah and the
abomination mm-hmm I met him in a moment
you seem like a nice guy he was via but
he created alphas
but first hello shall we were stuff done
yeah so that a guy nice guy yeah race we
good
like the shoe and love got [ __ ] like we
love this [ __ ] yeah like ice met him at
a back to the Battlestar Galactica Paley
Center panel that was at I think the
ArcLight money dome so you know you got
to be a [ __ ] nerd to be there in the
business and there you know we were and
he was ok man on him and I'm like Amy
Anna man you seem like a nice guy I'm
wait so he's writing you wrote a new
treatment may or misfit for Suicide
Squad too but he also wrote ready player
one did that Spielberg's direct yeah the
Ernest Cline book which is going to get
a big lady down in San Diego this year
is it really yeah a lot it on why didn't
we likes to bother it still we're coming
down yeah
I will be at San Diego are you gonna be
the sandy I will to being sent shall my
because we're doing a la that's right
there's only a couple tickets left
cassis mod calm you see me and Mark at
the American comedy club do and I'm
Batman live Saturday night Saturday
night 9:30 p.m. be there or be someplace
out that is way less cool and then we're
gone later on we're going to the funding
fest where's that st. John Brunswick
Canada we're on our way mellow Kannada
tickets at ceased mod comic see me and
Mark doing fat men on Batman live in the
great white north indeed and if you want
to see is anybody's else you talk to the
people who run that [ __ ] and give us a
call give us a shout find it on Twitter
come tweet us don't care we want to talk
for your money yeah there it is we're
putting it on Front Street we want to
money the people of us we have comfy or
women
this 103 first taste is free yeah yeah
yeah when we come to town we want your
money
um all right so news we got that's all
the news becoming Mel Gibson he's not
they want now he's snowing here that's
not happening I mean Warner Brothers The
Hollywood is wants to make you mad get
some happen again again and I say I want
to make a madman they want to make a
Mary had an Oscar nomination for haxor
Ridge which was the official welcome
back to Hollywood mogensen we have
forgiven you free sugar tits and
assorted awful things you've said in the
past Warner Brothers was like why don't
you come back and do this movie and for
whatever reason it didn't happen but the
fact that he got the call it's a big
deal to interested all the news that's
fit to print on the Internet that's what
we give you here on fat man on Batman
that's Batman Batman to the suite for
Batman Batman I'm Kevin and I'm mark
barnard come back next time same bat
time same bat Channel smoky sky more
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
[Music]